the battle for ukraine's eastern donbass
region rages on and russia is tightening
its grip on the key city of zvere
donetsk russian troops now control up to
80 percent of the city and are urging
ukrainian forces to surrender ukraine's
president vladimir zelinsky says ukraine
is outgunned in one of the bloodiest
battles of the war and has pleaded with
western allies to send more long-range
weapons he described the human cost of
the fighting as simply terrifying
bridges destroyed
the city of sierra donetsk is now almost
cut off
authorities say they're still able to
evacuate the wounded but the situation
for those still left is worsening and
fast
street battles are raging in the eastern
city
the governor of the region says it's
mostly under russian control
much of sivera donetsk has been
destroyed
authorities believe more than 500
civilians including children are
sheltering at the vast azot chemical
plant
they say the plant is under heavy
bombardment from russian forces
moscow and pro-russian separatists in
the region have issued an ultimatum to
the ukrainian troops still holding out
in the city
the ukrainian military units that are
stationed there remain there forever
they have two options either follow the
example of their colleagues and
surrender
or die
they have no other option
but the ukrainian president remains
defiant
we are dealing with absolute evil
and we have no other choice but to move
forward
free our entire territory
kick the occupiers out of all our
regions
and although now the width of our front
is already more than 2 500 kilometers
you can feel that the strategic
initiative is still on our side
in travelia a nearby town to the north
west of severedonetsk ukrainian police
raced to bring civilians to safety
many of them elderly
they didn't want to leave their homes
now they have no choice but to go
diy correspondence emmanuel
is in the ukrainian capital kiev emma we
understand that russia is
wants to plan rather to establish a
so-called humanitarian corridor on
wednesday to evacuate those civilians
who are trapped in that chemical plant
in this very donetsk what more have you
learned about that
well indeed it was an announcement made
earlier today by the russian ministry of
defence that they were ready to evacuate
the civilians who are trapped in that
chemical plant so it's it's the hazards
chemical plant in severe doneesk but as
we've just heard in the report there
were there were also those separatists
who were saying that ukrainian soldiers
only had the choice to surrender or to
die now this might remind you of a
situation we know very well sadly now is
that of mariupol where there were
ukrainian forces trapped along with
civilians in a power in a steel plant
this time in mario ball and now we're in
that situation where civilians need
darling need to be evacuated from severe
donetsk but under which conditions will
that depend on soldiers surrenders this
is not quite
clear yet what we know tonight that
cederodones is completely cut off from
the rest of ukrainian forces the three
bridges of the city has been destroyed
and up to 80 percent of the city is now
under russian control
uh indeed
emma the ukrainian president described
the situation as very dire and again
he's urging allies to send more heavy
weapons and ammunition
what exactly do we know about the state
of the ukrainian forces
well uh what we know is rather what the
ukrainian forces do not have to fight
and that's heavy weapons and president
vladimir zolensky really criticized
the western allies for uh being too
restrained in their decision-making and
what is a matter of diplomacy for
western power is a matter of life and
death for ukrainians here on the ground
who are paying with the price of blood
we've had some figures for the ministry
of defense here in ukraine of
up to a hundred saudis
dying ukrainian soldiers dying every day
since the beginning of the war and we
even had the presidential advisor who
gave a list of things that were needed
by the ukraine army a quite a concrete
like a quite straightforward list that
was published on twitter with 500 tanks
200 2 000 armored vehicles a thousand
drones just to give you an idea as to
how
desperate ukraine is now to receive the
weapons promised by the west
dw correspondent emmanuel reporting from
kyiv ukraine emma thank you
ambassador chansof why is it so
important for ukraine to be granted
candidate status into the eu right now
well hello thank you for your question
it is really important uh to get it now
because it's an existential challenge
for ukraine
to
sustain the pressure
uh to keep fighting
with russia
which is invading ukraine and for us
this green light this yes from the
european union it's something
which gives a hope to ukrainian people
which boost morale to ukrainian army
and it gives the direction of
development of the country for the mid
and long term future
you're talking about development of the
country there are some eu member states
who are more hesitant on the issue of
candidate states because they say that
reforms in ukraine are not happening
fast enough judicial reform
rule of law reform anti-corruption
reform what is it that you can offer
such member states what is it that
ukraine can do now to show its
commitment to these reforms
uh i would like to offer a few things to
those member states
first of all to be fair
with ukraine
and to look
in which state
the countries
which exceeded or got the membership
candidate status back in the 90s
or
later
in in which state of development in
which state
their
justice system or anti-corruption system
where on that moment
and i mean that ukraine is much more
advanced now
than those countries
where
some
20 years ago so you're basically saying
that it this wouldn't be an exception
for for ukraine that ukraine is actually
in a better position than many other
countries who'd been granted candidate
status have been no to the contrary
because
ukraine for a time being already
implemented
about 60 70 percent of the eu a key in
the different fields why because
association agreement
which was
negotiated and signed with the eu
is a is a very complex agreement and
what european union did
definitely they used the accession
experience
and presented ukraine the same let's say
more or less the same instrument the
same approach
but without clear membership perspective
then now what eu
has has to do is
really to compensate to give this
membership uh the candidate status
and uh to
to make
to make a fair
answer to ukraine
having said that georgia and moldova are
also taking this opportunity
to apply for the same thing do you feel
that this somehow
reduces ukraine's chances is this
somehow some kind of a competing for
this candidate status that perhaps takes
away
from from ukraine's chances at a time
when you're saying it's really urgent
for ukraine
look we
we are definitely not competing neither
with moldova nor with georgia
they have their right to apply to the
european union membership
what we are talking about we are talking
about exceptional situation an
exceptional case of ukraine
and this is something which differs us
what happens if ukraine doesn't get
candidate status what will ukraine do
ukraine will get candidate status
and we do not see
the plan
b in this situation
because we deserve it
because
this is a historic and crucial moment
for the eu to give the right answer
this is obviously still
under wraps to a large extent but we
hear that the leaders of france germany
and italy that is chancellor olaf
schultz president emmanuel macron and
president mario draghi will be in key of
talking to president zielinski
what would
kiev like to see from these leaders what
should they be taking to such a meeting
it's first of all it's a
very good news that they're coming to
ukraine to see their
their own eyes what is going on and how
they can support ukraine and also to see
what is the level of reform what is the
level of maturity of ukraine in the
context of this membership perspective
and definitely how to help ukraine
militarily so this is something they
need to do now and they need to do fast
finally uh ambassador
eu heads of state will be meeting again
at the end of this month can we expect
that president zielinski would be
addressing that meeting
so
it depends on the format and the program
of the meeting and the president
zelansky already several times addressed
the council so it's definitely for the
president of the council for the member
state to decide
uh how how to do this time
thank you so much we appreciate your
time ambassador thank you very much